sí pues ya a los simpatizantes de joe
biden que se acercaron se trataron de
acercar al capitolio simpatizantes
muchas mujeres muchos afroamericanos que
estaban tratando de expresar de alguna
manera su apoyo con pancartas con y
incluso con el música pues ya se están
empezando a retirar banderas de puerto
rico- banderas del movimiento black
light meter banderas de apoyo a bailén
se ven cercanos a donde estaban los
primeros periodistas los periodistas son
los que tuvieron más acceso precisamente
a cerca a las instalaciones del
capitolio pero algunos activistas
lograron filtrarse para expresar su
apoyo también hemos visto personas que
han venido a predicar mensajes de jesús
salva nuestros predicadores sin embargo
se han vinculado en el pasado con el
trump ismo y lo que han hecho es
intervenir en los mensajes y en las
comunicaciones de los periodistas se
viese un en un ambiente bastante
positivo
las reacciones de personas que caminan
que de pronto estuvieron presentes esa
positiva aquí vemos precisamente
personas que pasan con la bandera de
eeuu de puerto rico de blacklight máter
gente que celebra gente que esta mañana
antes del discurso precisamente y en la
ceremonia de inauguración salí a caminar
con las camisetas de joe biden de la
campaña de job aid en la ciudad que es
una ciudad bastante demócrata pues ha
recibido y recibe bien este evento de
inauguración y pues esta nueva
presidencia de iovine presidente número
46 de eeuu
cristóbal aparentemente esa sensación
esa tensión que había más temprano en la
mañana por el tema de seguridad por
estos 25 mil soldados de la guardia
nacional esa atención ya ha bajado de
hecho ya ha salido un poco más el sol
ya la temperatura ha subido un poco allí
en la capital de eeuu da esa sensación
por lo menos un poco más de calma y
menos tensión
si da esa sensación más calma
recordemos que desde ayer por la mañana
los puentes que comunican a virginia con
el distrito de columbia estaban cerrados
y el distrito de columbia estaba
prácticamente incomunicado precisamente
para evitar el ingreso de simpatizantes
extremos y nacionalistas blancos a el
distrito de columbia durante el evento
de inauguración además de el despliegue
militar hubo una alianza un estilo de
trabajo conjunto con la empresa privada
y el bien vi por ejemplo dejó de
alquilar inmuebles días antes de la
inauguración los hoteles estaban
haciendo super vi subir y
supervigilancia a la gente que llegaba a
hacer check-in en sus hoteles incluso
las empresas de carlos estaban también
pasando haciendo todo un screening y
haciendo pues revisión del pasado de las
personas que querían alquilar carros
para evitar pues a sembrar bombas en la
ciudad que era una de las amenazas que
estaban también latentes y que la
alcaldesa de la ciudad
muy elevados ya había manifestado su
preocupación también al respecto pero si
el ambiente es de más calma y obviamente
con los eventos que van a seguir en esta
inauguración ese pues es seguramente
ahora más acogida en otros lugares de la
ciudad y la calma se propagara un poco
más
cristóbal hace unos minutos hablaba con
unos con uno de nuestros invitados sobre
la relación con la prensa que tuvo el
gobierno de donald trump usted lleva
muchos años viviendo en washington ha
trabajado cubriendo la casa blanca y
cubriendo la administración trump no
solamente para france24 en el pasado lo
hizo para otros medios de comunicación
cómo era esa sensación cómo era cubrir
la presidencia de trump cómo era estar
en la casa blanca cubriendo esta
presidencia con esta relación esta tensa
relación entre medios y presidencia
pues nosotros éramos el enemigo del
pueblo
donald trump desde que empezó su mandato
crítico en los medios de comunicación y
lo responsabilizó de muchos problemas
que tenía a eeuu ha responsabilizado a
los medios de comunicación de haberse
robado las elecciones porque habían
nombrado con anticipación al ganador de
las elecciones a pesar de conocerse pues
ya los resultados ha responsabilizado a
los medios de comunicación de no darle
el cubrimiento necesario a las políticas
de él a sus logros y pues eso hizo que
cuando entrábamos a la casa blanca los
propios oficiales de prensa nos trataban
con desdén e de alguna manera en el
capitolio los jefes de prensa de los
senadores y congresistas republicanos
también a los medios de comunicación
internacionales nacionales también nos
trataban con cierto tipo de desprecio lo
que se espera de ahora adelante con la
prensa es que ese trato ese trato en la
casa blanca en el departamento de estado
en el congreso
de justicia en el departamento de
defensa en el pentágono incluso sea
mucho más cercano que haya más cercanía
y por ende mucho más flujo de
información entre el el gobierno
entrante y los medios de comunicación lo
que han dicho también algunas personas
es que la estrategia era precisamente
aislar a los medios de comunicación para
que los canales de el presidente
saliente el ex presidente ya donald
trump los canales de redes sociales sus
vías de comunicación fuesen mucho más
grandes y fue y pudiese pues agrupar a
sus simpatizantes en esos canales
pues hablaremos en unos meses cristóbal
para ver cuál es el balance que usted
puede hacer de la relación de la prensa
con la nueva administración
byd en harris muchas gracias cristóbal
por este reporte